voici nos apps tarder moureu hussards
sixième roman à 33 ans
les proches de laëtitia est réglée info
web ou vitriol interview à l'afp
bonsoir bonsoir tu as publié précautions
d'usagé la table ronde un triomphe chez
orban nos amis les lettres chez orban
des gens impossible de nouveau à la
table ronde lettre ouverte à françois
truffaut chez albin michel et tu publies
chez albin michel les anges de laetitia
et par là j'ai pas alterner d'éditeur ça
fait pas mal qu'elle achetait à 33 ans
ça va ouais 6e dit qu'un serait temps
que ça se vende c'est un peu de jours la
livrée à madame finir d'abord au
quotidien là dedans pourquoi les proches
de laëtitia mais les hanches de laëtitia
pour tout te dire c'est un pari avec
denis tillinac
parce que justement à madame figaro il
ya une fille qui s'appelle laetitia et
qui est un très beau cul surtout tenter
un blue jeans et on parlait toujours de
des hanches de laetitia alors le sujet
bon c'est à toulouse les années 70 après
l'élection de giscard
ce qui paraît déjà vieux tout le monde
en ce moment nous bassine avec les pays
de l'est
ce que personne n'avait prédit et à
l'époque je me souviens si quelqu'un
avait osé dire que mitterrand saint
geours président de la république
il aurait été la risée n'a semblé et je
crois que c'était la fin d'une période
alors toulouse la province
l'adolescence cette fois trois étudiants
qui en fou de ballon et qui sont plus ou
moins un mois de la même fille qui
s'appelle laetitia qui est la plus belle
fille de la victime
moi j'ai pas de couvrir de compliments
de ce que ça prenne vraiment pas sérieux
si tu veux tu seras peut-être le seul au
renard mais je trouve que par rapport à
toutes les premiers bouquins ou un avis
on attend un peu de maturité un peu de
profondeur et c'est là ça commence enfin
je sais pas peut-être que c'est le recul
ça fait déjà quinze ans c'est pour ça
alors peut-être que j'ai un peu
dégraisser jeter tous les tics
d'adolescence et des moments très forts
l'amour de véronique way elle n'ait pas
le dire c'est la 6e place non parce que
véronique qui sait c'est la bonne copine
qu'on a tous quand on est jeunes chez
qui on va se voir des coups à
l'improviste puisque personne n'a envie
de sauter et puis c'est celle à qui on
fait pas attention et qui un jour se
suicider le mariage de laëtitia bah oui
parce que laëtitia c'est la petite a dû
connaître ça se voit qu'ils aient de
province pour moi tu as toujours une
fille qui cristallise un peu les
fantasmes de tous les types à cet âge là
et qui en fait en a rien à cirer qui
épouse un optique
quand on lit ce bouquin on comprend son
admiration pour truffaut et pourquoi tu
écris cette lettre ouverte à françois
truffaut parce qu on peut dire ce niveau
baiser volé nos remerciements c'est vrai
ça c'est un continent qui me touche je
dis pas ça parce que j'ai un copain
je prends les baisers alors les nouveaux
hussards c'est quoi les nouveaux usages
bizarrement c'est une invention de bhl
quand jean marie roy a sorti chez
grasset son livre sur le suicide
il a dit aux gars 1 à l'événement
faudrait faire une espèce de truc
pendant ses livres et les nouveaux une
soirée
cela dit c'était pas une mauvaise idée
puisque
l'étiquette nous colle encore oddo est à
toi aussi et il ya pire j'ai mis un
nouveau bus arc neo certes rien ou
dadaïste postmoderne
c'est toi qui disais qu'ils se
demandaient les nouveaux lui sert s'il
fallait entrer au bar ou à la pléiade
bah si on peut faire les deux ce sera
pas mal entrer au bain ça y est non
c'est pas le en général j'ai plus de
problèmes pour en sortir dans nos amis
les lettres car tenait à mort sur le
milieu littéraire et on tard on l'a
accusé d'être un peu trop prudent tu
penses que ça avait été prudente a eu
des mais je sais pas moi je me souviens
pas bien de ceux de ce livre qui en fait
était un livre inutile parce que c'était
idiot de consacrer 150 pages à des gens
que tout le monde oubliera jours mais je
sais pas je me souviens que j'attaquais
jean-daniel que j'attaquais l'équipe du
matin
cela dit ça leur apporte les changements
et moi je vois pas pourquoi j'aurais
plus d'élan étant donné que c'est un
milieu de gens un peu las c'est qu'ils
ont peur de tout donc si eux se
souviennent de ce que j'ai dit sur moi
je me souviens pas du mal jammeh avait
dit du pamphlet comme un moyen de se
faire des amis trouvé que ce n'est pas
assez dur aujourd'hui j'espérais un
pamphlet sur jamais qui serait pour moi
c'est pas lui
alors on va voir comment tu es
aujourd'hui dans le pamphlet on va
passer à l'interview où tout est prêt en
avant
alors on a commencé avec les éditeurs
bizarrement parce qu'on parle toujours
des auteurs a commencé et qu'ils
éditeurs comme ça on va te fâcher
définitivement avec lui les éditeurs
parisiens à nouveau des little ya le
tiens d'ailleurs oui alors on commence
avec françoise verny tampon squat
françoise une grosse dame sympathique
j'écrirai pas de livres pour elle parce
que en général elle prend des gens qui
n'explique pas pour leur mettre une idée
de roman dans les pattes et aureilhan
pour les gens qui publie chez elle
bah oui moi j'ai pas besoin de quelqu'un
pour nantes et à écrire quelqu'un pour
m'empêcher d'écrire
jean marc roberts au seuil jean marc
roberts il a refusé le début de mon
premier roman donc pour moi c'est un
très bon les éditeurs olivier orban
olivier orban c'est une canaille
sympathique qui est devenu généreuse
puisque maintenant l'argent des presses
de la cité n'est plus le sien et il le
donne et plus généreux qu'avant bah je
crois c'est bien placé pour le savoir
richard du coup c'est ton éditeur chez
albin michel richard ducousset basse et
un éditeur donc un gangster sympathique
et puis c'est le seul type et qui tu
puisses déjeuner sans qu'ils te parle de
littérature et ça c'est pas déplaisant
daniel rondeau quai voltaire bat daniel
rondeau le pauvre je crois que ça pas
été son année parce que son roman
c'était rentes est partout et j'ai
appris récemment qu'il avait été tirée
du quai voltaire donc que je peux pas
internes au mal
on va passer aux médias mois pour se
lâcher encore plus bernard pivot sur al
attassi mois pour bernard pivot il ya
deux ans je lui ai conseillé d'arrêter
son émission j'ai vu que ma vie et je
suis prêt à lui pardonner
jérôme garcin l'événement du jeudi
jérôme garcin c'est mon bon socialiste
comme céline avec son bon juif c'est un
type qui a fait un peu le contraire de
nous tous qui avions commencé à
téléphoner à l'âge de 25 ans lui et
c'était l'époque où il était très
sérieux et maintenant il se met à
cartonner et il est tout étonné de voir
que les gens lui en veulent mais c'est
plutôt bien qu'ils continuent serge july
libération serge july pour moi c'est le
renégat absolue c'est j'ai compris ce
que c'était que mai 68 enfin un jour ou
à monaco
j'étais dans un hôtel il y avait changé
lisez et j'ai vu julie venir présenter à
michel drucker en personne
un truc sur pourquoi écrivez-vous que tu
dit à libération
et là je me suis dit vraiment les
gauchistes c'est pas ça c'est des mecs
vénaux philippe tesson temps l'ancien
patron que dilemme paris il doit tout
autre mille francs jean françois kahn
l'événement du jeudi encore jean
françois kahn c'est le devin du
postillon parce que il connaît tout
l'avenir mais moi je j'admire je
comprends pas pourquoi mais il réussit à
faire dans l'événement jean daniel jean
daniel pour moi c'est la publicité kamel
au dos du nouvel observateur la
couverture de la de la boîte de
cigarettes
jean françois bizot actuelle 10 oc
l'auteur d'un bon livre qui s'appelait
les est classé et puis un bon patron de
presse mais un type qui s'est gâché qui
a eu peur d'écrire des livres
georges marc benamou globe
georges marc benamou c1 le ponton de bhl
on va passer aux écrivains pour de vrai
à voilà avec un des plus grand pôle nord
au pôle man c'est tout c'est la vitesse
le style l'élégance et puis la
souffrance ul et il ya quinze jours en
suisse pour voir le château qui
l'habitait à vevey
je pensais que ce serait un truc genre
la belle et la bête est en réalité c'est
un tout petit château bord du lac un peu
sinistre vraiment un truc un truc
d'exilés pas de l'amour du tout et ce
type et en a bavé drieu drilhole plus
beaux suicider
limiers nimier l'accident de voiture le
plus bête de l'histoire littéraire d eau
d eau
notre modèle à tous je pense irlande
pour l'irlande et la grèce geneviève
dormann geneviève dormann la seule femme
dont je lise les livres 102 touches
ennemis d'allah franck bernard france
c'est celle par un petit peu à la fois
le type qui t'a double comme un
chevalier et puis il a un côté don
corleone quand même parce que c'est un
un vieux requins patrick besson patrick
besson c'est un un excellent écrivain
peut-être le meilleur de sa génération
qui est devenu mon ami et mon voisin
alors je vous passe la nahb
c'est le type qui s'était cassé la
gueule par georges marc benamou donc un
type qui restera dans l'histoire
vous aurez vers l'allié qui ne connaît
pas et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu